our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us so this
morning an inspiring little boy from
maryland with
great hair we have to say he's on a
mission to help those in need
this little seven-year-old reached out
earlier this year to the residents of a
rural
indian reservation in south dakota to
send badly needed supplies
and as chip reid shows us this ambitious
second grader think about that ambition
in second grade
didn't stop there i dream big
you dream big so big that kavanaugh bell
at four feet tall filled two 53-foot
trailers to help people
he'd never met how did you get two
truckloads full
of supplies it's magic it's magic
it's operation magic operation magic
magic may be the only explanation that
makes sense for how this maryland
second grader raised more than 36
thousand dollars for food and clothing
and then had it trucked halfway across
the country welcome to pine ridge
to this south dakota reservation one of
the poorest places
in the nation what's up guys kavanaugh
first saw it two years ago
on a trip to mount rushmore with his
mother lacy
they were so grateful that someone from
1500 miles away
that's only seven would put together
this effort
for some kids that would be enough for
one year but kavanaugh
saw the need back home and began
building these mobile pantries he stocks
with supplies
to help his community how much of it is
coming from you
and how much of it is coming from him i
would say like 95 of it's coming from
him
i'll throw out something that i think is
relatively doable in my adult schedule
and kavanagh will be like no that's not
enough it started at age
four when he helped his mom send safe
drinking water to flint michigan
when coronavirus hit kavanaugh created
care packages for seniors
so they wouldn't have to go out shopping
that's when some big names
noticed in maryland a seven-year-old boy
used his own birthday money to buy
meals for dozens of senior citizens i've
helped
eight 8 126 people
so i guess you could say i'm kind of
busy do you get nervous talking to
important famous people like kamala
harris no
[Laughter]
i get shaky and then i just i'm clutch
you're clutch yeah but kavanaugh wasn't
always that
confident he endured bullying in
preschool
a lot of darkness inside of me and where
did that darkness come from
it was just from them being mean but it
gave him
a mission to help others avoid feeling
hopeless
you hope people will be inspired yeah to
do what to
just do what i'm doing and change the
world and help other people
yeah kavanagh hopes eventually to be
mayor
and maybe even president he's only
seven makes you wonder what he'll
accomplish when he's eight
for cbs this morning chip reid
gaithersburg maryland
great last line what is he going to do
when he's eight oh
boy really amazing i mean incredible i
vote for
mayor already he's already got
bipartisan support kamala harris and
president trump
and i like that term i clutch
bravo to you and mom too